i wanted to get uh this coach on because
i think he has been uh
he and uh his army football team has
been royally screwed and i don't
normally uh
you know start a conversation with uh an
editorial comment like that but uh that
is the way i am bringing in the head
coach of army football jeff monken how
are you coach
i'm great thanks for the opportunity no
you bet i wish i wish it was different
circumstances
quite frankly so can you walk everyone
through about uh
how you learned that you did not have a
bowl opponent for
the independence bowl and uh why the
bowl is not being played etc and so on
and so forth can you set the table if
you don't mind
we've had a an agreement with uh with
the independence bowl since
the middle of last season they they were
gracious enough to uh to partner with us
to play in their game in 2020 2022 and
2024
we were thrilled for the opportunity
it's a great bowl game
a historic bowl and and
obviously with the season we've had we
were excited on sunday morning
to uh to find out finally who would be
playing in the game and
as the day went along um we
we started to to get word that
we may perhaps be getting shut out and
and it uh you know it's just the the
system that is in place which
gives a lot of teams an opportunity to
play it gave us an opportunity to play
in 2016 when we were seven and five and
and
we were considered a a five win team
because of our schedule
uh we got in there were enough bowl
games and i love that i love that we've
got
a lot of opportunities for teams to be
able to play
and so we wanted to to partner with
with the bowl games to have an automatic
tie-in just like the conference teams do
which we do
and uh i i g
i'm i'm not privy to to all of the
conversations or all the information but
the independence bowl uh they they've
extended invitations to some other teams
that
either weren't interested in going to
the independence bowl or weren't
interested in playing us
and and were able to go to other bowl
games or just opted out
entirely and said rather than going to
the independent army we're not going to
play at all
and uh for whatever reason they've got
their reasons but
that that left the the whole bowl system
with less inventory in terms of teams
than there are
bowl slots so as of yesterday there were
an odd number of teams
that wanted to play and obviously you
needed
an even number of teams to uh to
satisfy everybody and with the
conference affiliations with bowles and
the
the agreements that have been in place
for those teams
and those conferences those bowl games
uh we were shut out
and and uh just very unfortunate to have
a season like we did
and have a great senior class like we've
got those guys were devastated to get
that news as you can imagine our guys
have looked forward to the opportunity
to play and and uh
and so we're we're kind of sitting here
with our fingers crossed we certainly
don't want to wish
still will on anybody but uh we're just
hoping that
somehow some way that maybe there'll be
a team that
that can't play or decides they don't
want to play that we'll be able to fill
that slot and
our team's ready to go if that's the
case yeah you're the uh
army west point director of athletics
mike buddy saying that your team does
that everyone deserves better period um
that's that's an excellent way to put it
so you you beat air force you get the
commander-in-chief trophy and you're
feeling high and then you get this news
and it's just as a gut punch
why do you why do you why do you think i
said that there are teams having reasons
and i understand there are some teams
that will be like you know what it
it's uh it's coveted 19 if we have one
less game of exposure for our players
that's that's one way to
put it are are are teams afraid to play
you you think
too oh i i don't know why they would be
i mean well you're good well
you know we don't we don't have anybody
get offered scholarships by
but a whole bunch of other teams that
play football at this level so
um you know we're not we're not we're
not an overly talented team i think we
got a good team we got guys that play
hard and care about each other and
execute well
and that's why we've been able to win
but i guess what
what i i don't understand rich is
we've fought really hard for this season
everybody everybody in college football
there were there were conferences that
that essentially opted out in the middle
of the summer
and teams in those leagues and
individual players in those leagues and
parents of
those players fought and protested and
and we got college football back and
so some of those same teams who
fought so hard and wanted so badly to
play
this season now when the bowl season
comes up
they don't want to play and i don't
understand and i i know that everybody's
been through a lot
but i would tell you i don't know that
anybody's been through more than our
players have
to to to come in here on june the first
which they did
some of them now our travel squad had
been off campus three times we had three
road games this year
but for our guys that don't travel they
haven't been off campus they haven't
seen their parents
they haven't been through the mcdonald's
drive through or or anything like that
since june first
so our guys have been through a lot and
yet they remain
committed to wanting to to finish this
season and play in a bowl game and
and they've earned that opportunity and
and so
i know teams have been through a lot you
know i i hear the stories and
you know bret brett brennan's team up
there at san jose they practice at a
different
college the whole year and stanford's
been practicing a different place
you know i get it there's been people
been through a lot and and it's been
different for every college football
player
and every team but this team these young
men
have made a commitment to this nation
they've made a commitment to every one
of their brothers
that plays college football that
we will defend the freedoms and our way
of life
after we graduate so that
football players and football teams and
fans can continue to enjoy this game the
way we do that
no other country in the world celebrates
college sports like we do
you know that's on the backs of of our
men and women
who have served who can continue to
serve and those that will serve
and we are uniquely positioned as an
academy
to play in a bowl game the only the only
academy that that
is is prepared to play in a bowl game
this year
to represent all those men and women
that serve and i will assure you that
we've been through a lot but our our
our families of of our soldiers sailors
and airmen
all over the world uh those that are
deployed and haven't seen their loved
ones for a year
who are going into harm's way every day
they're going through a lot
and they deserve to be represented by a
group of men who wear their colors
and who are uniquely positioned to
represent them
and you know that that's why i want our
guys to play
because not one they want to play but
two who we represent
makes it all that more important in my
opinion because as as you point out
coach uh jeff monken of army football
you know there are
many bowl eligible teams who have been
through a lot
and have had to sacrifice in a manner
that let's be honest we we
we are asking um you know teenagers and
men
who are who are just getting out of
teenage years to do
okay and sacrifice so we can enjoy
football
but there's only one bowl eligible team
who is
uh about to about to in the future
go through a lot as you point out for us
as a country
so uh do you point this out to teams
that
may may may be interested in playing a
bowl game but then say no to you
i mean is that something that you do
tell them
like that they're i'm i'm not involved
in those conversations so
those that's at a much higher level than
me and uh
is that i'm sure that is that being
communicated people understand that and
you know what they're not obligated to
to give us any charity
they're they're they're entitled to play
in whatever game they want
and and say yes or no and that's that's
what our guys are going to fight for
yeah the freedom for for all of us as
americans to say yes or no
and and not be told what to do and our
guys proudly will do that i promise you
but
you know we just we want an opportunity
to play and it really would have taken
just one more team
to opt in and say we'll do it
and uh and so now we're just kind of the
position of of
of waiting our guys are preparing our
our players said coach we
want to prepare in case something
happens
we want to be ready for the opportunity
and you know you talk about going
through a lot
and to sit here and want to continue to
prepare and practice and plan
uh you know to to to to
fundamentally try to get better as a
football player not even knowing if
you'll ever have a chance to play again
for these seniors that says a lot for
for these guys and
and uh and that's that's why i'm
fighting so desperately
to to get them an opportunity so what is
again as you say it's it's going on um
uh uh up the flow chart here to try and
get it get an opponent
uh who who's helping i mean who who's
here i mean who's part of the
if you will cavalry what do you got
we're just advocating for our team and
at this point
what i don't i don't i don't wish you
will on anybody i don't want anybody to
have an unhealthy team but
the way college football has gone this
year 20 percent of the games have been
canceled or postponed
i can only assume that there's going to
be some some bowl games
that are you know that are left kind of
okay what are we going to do we've got a
team that tested with too many guys
positive and they they don't have a
healthy enough team to play
we we need to play this game army's
going to be there ready to go
so if that's kind of what we're
preparing for
if that would happen that uh we'll
we'll be prepared to play jeff monken
army football coach here uh on the rich
eisen show
uh before i let you go uh again you know
i know we've been talking about how the
system is
is an unfortunate system but um in terms
of uh coach's poll you are part of it
and i did see your poll uh through usa
today your final
coach's poll submission and i'd love to
ask you uh
why you chose alabama ohio state clemson
and texas a m
as your top four with indiana and notre
dame cincinnati
oklahoma behind them how did you go
about your process
those are all great football teams and
it's really hard
to try to decide who the who the best
teams are who the most worthy teams are
any one of those teams if they expanded
the playoff to eight teams i think all
eight of them deserve to go
they all have a chance and and they all
might
one might be able to beat any one of the
others i really believe that those are
all really really
strong outstanding well-coached football
teams
um but i like everybody else kind of had
to evaluate
and i try to watch as much college
football as i can i'm
i vote in that poll and i take it
seriously and i think
it's my duty to know as much as i can
about each of those teams and watch them
carefully
and and i've tried to do that and i just
felt like the four teams that
that i put uh as my top four
were at this point the the best
teams the teams that were were perhaps
uh
most worthy of having the opportunity to
play for a national championship and
and comparing scores and
and opponents and uh
i i guess recently how they played and
they played well uh down the stretch and
at the end of the season i think that
matters
uh not necessarily how you played at the
beginning but how you play at the end
and uh and they were hard decisions
because i i have tremendous respect
for all of those coaches all all eight
of those schools that you mentioned
and uh and for college football coaches
in general i grew up a coach's kid i've
always been around football i love
coaches
and and what they do for for young
people and
their commitment to people development
and it's hard it's hard to knowing that
that's going to be public and people say
why didn't you pick our team or
but i i just felt like those were the
were the right for
in my opinion and everybody's entitled
their opinion it's why they have
a lot of people vote and uh and there's
you know obviously disagreement on on
all on all accounts
coach i appreciate the call i appreciate
uh
what you are uh doing uh and
and what you are attempting to do for
your your players
and i would just can you thank them all
from all of us here again for
you know i know currently they're uh
defending
and uh their own uh figurative turf
right now but in advance of doing that
for us and defending our constitution as
they're about to do
and the mulder of these men that you are
on the gridiron and in the locker room
and in the campus and in the community i
say thank you and
uh you deserve an opponent i i'd love
i'd love for you to get one
and um and uh and thank you for the call
well i i appreciate the opportunity and
uh
and i can tell you the only things that
our guys need
is the opportunity to serve their nation
that's that's that's thanks enough
they they consider an honor a privilege
to do that i love our guys
i love these players and uh and i know
they want to play
and so i i will fight every
tooth and nail to get them the
opportunity and perhaps it'll happen
and perhaps it won't but uh but we're
gonna we're gonna make every effort
to reward these guys they deserve it and
uh rich thanks thanks a lot for the
opportunity
and uh anytime keep talking about this
team because they're a great bunch of
guys
my pleasure my pleasure thank you coach
thank you for the call
there you go i love that i love that
i love that beat navy but he's also
saying that this team will represent all
those who serve
our country but at the very end though
every name
his own version of gohan hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here